let's talk to the europe minister james
cleverley
good morning mr cleverley
trevor good morning
the munich security conference continues
today um are we any closer to a
diplomatic solution to this crisis or is
the threat of invasion as great as ever
well the simple truth is that russia
still has a huge and unprecedented
number of troops on the ukrainian border
whilst those troops are there and whilst
they have uh combat enablers that means
the logistics the medical support that
kind of stuff that you only really need
for a full military conflict it's it's
not explained away just by an exercise
whilst those things are there the threat
is real and the attack could come at any
time now the prime minister made it
clear we are still going to pursue
diplomatic
routes we still want to avoid a conflict
rather than see one roll out and so
that's what we're going to continue
doing and we're going to try and make
sure that vladimir putin understands
that an invasion would come at a huge
cost both human costs and financial cost
to him and the people around him that
may be your hope mr cleverley but the
president of the united states on friday
told washington
reporters in washington that
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that
war is
coming well
unfortunately none of the things that we
had hoped to see none of the
de-escalation when i was in the united
nations in new york uh at the tail end
of last week both myself and all the
other people speaking called for
de-escalation
we haven't seen that we've seen
increased troop numbers we've seen now
more aggressive more belligerent
activity by the russia by russia we're
not seeing the things that we had hoped
to see so unfortunately at the moment
a
an attack an invasion seems far more
likely than unlikely but we will
continue to work to try and avert that
far more likely than unlikely you put
the chances of invasion higher than 50
50.
well at the moment as i say everything
that we see
indicates that an invasion is very very
highly likely and very very imminent now
we will continue working every day that
we can prevent this conflict is a good
day at work so we will continue working
to try and avert
conflict
to let russia know to let vladimir putin
know
that there will be significant
consequences from the international
community including from the uk through
sanctions
i'm just trying to get clarity really on
on where the government's mind is at the
foreign secretary your boss liz trust
says that mr putin
will not stop at the ukraine and he at
ukraine and he will then target the
baltic states now
if the kremlin really does have these
expansionist plans that you believe that
then why not level with us and say that
we had better prepare for war
because
in the end if that's what he's going to
do
there's not going to be any way of
stopping him other than militarily
well we
are trying very hard to prevent conflict
from happening what we have seen is we
have seen incursions from russia
into crimea into the donbass
into
georgia and to other parts of central
europe so when the foreign secretary
says that you know this is not going to
be it
all the history has shown us that there
is continued aggression coming out from
the kremlin we're trying to prevent that
we're trying to stop that but we also
recognize that the eastern nato allies
are also um
watching what's going on and we're
seeking to give them reassurance of our
strength of unity through nato so we're
reinforcing
our eastern nato allies now ukraine is
not part of nato and so that's a very
different prospect and what we're
looking to do is deter
through
diplomatic means and the threat of
sanctions
but the simple truth is russia has shown
itself
to be a very aggressive neighbor and we
need them to stop
but it looks here like that there is
the potential let's put it that way for
a spiral in his speech at the munich
security conference yesterday the prime
minister listed the troops that he's
sending to estonia and poland
he talked about an increased aerial
presence in southeastern europe and the
deployment of warships in the
mediterranean and the black sea
look
is there a danger that we're making
conflict more likely by such an obvious
buildup of forces
well the thing that's made made conflict
more likely trevor is the nearly 150 000
russian troops amassed on ukrainian uh
borders on the north the east and the
southern borders of ukraine an
unprecedented a larger accumulation of
military power
since at any time since the second world
war that is what uh the reality is we
are reacting nato is a purely defensive
alliance it has never expanded by force
it has never expanded by coercion the
countries that join nato join nato
because they uh they want to exist under
the umbrella of shared protection that
nato provides the aggressor here is
russia and what we are trying to do is
to say that we will stand by our friends
and allies in nato and we will support
uh democracy
sovereignty uh the rule of law when it
comes to ukraine
i suppose the question here and you
talked to a moment ago about the lessons
of history
and that the lesson sometimes that we've
learned is that events can take on a
momentum of their own and build up on
both sides could take us potentially to
a place where
nobody feels that they can back down and
whilst you and the diplomats are using
the language
of resolution and reconciliation and
finding solutions
the facts on the ground
point to further conflict uh and i
suppose what i'm really asking is to
what extent are we in danger of playing
a part
uh as it were in
creating
uh that spiral towards uh conflict
well trevor let's let's let's think
about what the credible alternative
would be do we think it is realistic
that we watch the largest build-up of
military troops since the second world
war on the border of the sovereign
nation a border which has already been
invaded by russia in uh 2014. do we sit
back
pretend that's not happening
and uh and send the signal both to
russia and more broadly that we do not
take seriously threats and intimidation
towards uh democratic states that's not
a credible
position we are working
round the clock to try and prevent this
conflict but we're all making it clear
that we support our nato allies
and that's why those troop deployments
have happened
but also
we support we support the sovereignty
and democracy and the rule of law when
it comes to uh ukraine the
heroes from russia
let's cut through this
we have these forces we are
pointing out that they are there
if there is an invasion
how will we or the nato allies use those
forces what are our military
options well
we've got to understand there are
two things kind of wrapped up in that
question
uh nato uh will support itself or
support the member states of nato
ukraine is not a nato member state but
we have given equipment support and
training support to uh ukraine through
operation indeed but he's not he's not
invading hungary he's not in va invading
poland
he's potentially invading ukraine so how
could we use our forces in the case of
an invasion of ukraine
so that's the point i'm saying the the
forces that we're sending to our nato
allies of the nato defense for ukraine
we have given the uh support of
defensive military equipment and
training we are not envisaging sending
uh british or nato forces to ukraine we
are we have helped them defend
themselves through that training and
equipment support
and
we have laid a
regime a sanctions regime which means
that we could apply meaningful and
painful sanctions to the money people
around vladimir putin if he were to take
part in or if he were to initiate an
invasion but it's really important that
we see the distinction between those two
things
all right well let's let's talk about
the money um
here's what the prime minister
had to say yesterday on this question of
financial sanctions
he said i don't think that it's fair to
say the uk hasn't done a huge amount on
dirty money whether it's from russia or
anywhere else actually globally we've
been out in the lead in tackling global
corruption in tracing the sources of
ill-gotten gains we've imposed some very
tough sanctions if you recall after the
russian annexation of crimea of
sevastopol in 2014. now one of the
main instruments that he's talking about
then tackling global corruption is the
unexplained wealth order which requires
individuals to reveal the source of
their vast sums of money um can you tell
me
how many of those have been issued since
boris johnson
uh became prime minister
i don't i don't have that figure i don't
know i i do
well
you
you suggested in your question that is
the
main way i don't necessarily agree that
is that
i'm not suggesting it i'm telling you
that's what your colleague said to me
when they were sitting here liz truss um
and another of your cabinet colleagues
said that to me in the last uh two weeks
that is the thing that they pinned uh
their hopes on
i would be surprised if that's quite the
language they use but nevertheless well
i can show you the clip if you really
want to get into that but but they said
it to me
so the point the point is that we have a
range we have a range
of uh ways of dealing with illicit
finance we are indeed one of the
leaders in terms of tackling uh illicit
finance we take it very very seriously
and we're working
with
other financial jurisdictions around the
world to make sure that the
the whole global approach because it
does need to be a global approach to
illicit finance is coordinated and
robust the point is
that the prime minister has made it
absolutely clear
through the sanctions regime the
expanded sanctions regime the toughest
sanction regime that we have ever had
with regards to russian money is now in
place and were there to be an invasion
it would be used and those individuals
those money people around vladimir putin
would absolutely feel it we're making it
very very clear that we will respond and
we will respond robustly if there is an
invasion into ukraine
if i may say so the prime minister's
made it very clear in words but i think
mr putin and others look at actions
these orders have actually been used
five times since they came into uh being
and none of them has been used against
russians and in addition to that what we
also know is that uh the international
financial system assisted by russian
legislation it makes it almost im
impossible to trace uh the source of
this dirty money a lot of the people
that have been named uh
bring their money into london via other
jurisdictions cayman islands cyprus and
so on
how can vladimir putin really take this
seriously when
he can see by our actions we just don't
use the powers that we've already got
never mind any powers that you might
want to introduce now
well
one of the things you have to understand
trevor is the difference between an
unexplained wealth order and
sanctions the sanctions are a different
vehicle we have used sanctions as the
prime minister has said in the in the
quote that you have given we have used
sanctions in response to the sales
repoisoning an attack
by russian intelligence agents on
british soil
we coordinated the largest uh
expulsion or yeah we facilitated the
largest coordinated expulsion of
undocumented russian agents in response
to that so we have already applied
sanctions we are willing to apply more
so the hypothesis you're putting forward
that somehow we haven't taken action is
just not borne out by the facts we have
and we will in the event of a another
incursion into ukraine by russia
all right let's talk uh if we may for a
moment about covid prime minister is
apparently going to announce the lifting
of all coveted restrictions tomorrow
uh is it all over
well the thing with the disease is never
completely over but what we have seen
is because of the the research that we
do in the genomic research that we do
here in the uk world-class
research because of the
production distribution
and
[Music]
and
the
vaccination program the booster program
we have broken the link between
infections and hospitalizations we are
we are seeing the uh we're seeing that
the disease now it's it's changed into a
much much milder form we will of course
remain vigilant that's incredibly
important but we are in a position now
where we can follow the data follow
the the science evidence that we've seen
and move back towards a normal state
where we we recognize we have to live
with disease
we've always had to live with diseases
we're going to have to live with this
disease but we do also want to get back
to normal
can we just clear one thing up for uh
local authority leaders who've noted
that um the press release from the
government on this says that local
authorities will still be expected to
manage outbreaks with pre-existing
health powers
is that a signal to them that if there
is a further
virus outbreak a new variation so on
that there won't be
any more money available
now
trevor what this is is this is a
recognition that we've had pre-existing
contingency planning
for disease outbreaks at local
government level when i was uh when i
was working with um the prime minister
when he was mayor of london i chaired
the london resilience forum and we had
contingency plans
for how local authorities would deal
with disease outbreaks in their area
what we're saying now is that
is that the the era where we're having
additional
differentiated
uh responses to covid is going to be
over and we're going to move back to the
pre-existing regime where local
authorities have plans and these plans
are are well circulated well-tested uh
and and um
pre-existing and those are what we're
expecting local
local authorities to rely on from this
point but from from when the
announcements made moving forward
and they will but they will have to uh
carry out those plans based on their
existing resources there won't be a new
bunch of money from the treasury
well as as
this as we've seen with omnicron uh
clovid is now
much more similar to other less
um
also
less well-known diseases which are in
circulation which local authorities have
plans to deal with have plans to deal
with and what we're saying is that is
the regime that we're going to move
towards
all right um you just pointed out that
you've been
at the
prime minister's right hand in various
ways for many years from his days in
city hall so you know him
pretty well um let me ask you a couple
of questions about uh the questionnaire
which he's now returned to the
metropolitan police uh outlining his
responses to their questions about
parties and downing street and all of
that um if the prime minister were
issued with a fixed penalty notice will
that be made public
so i haven't
discussed this directly with him i
understand he's made a statement about
uh putting uh information in the public
domain you have to rely on the on the
words that he has already given to that
when i uh get the chance to speak to him
i have to say i speak to him about the
issues we've been speaking about
previously about uh the situation with
uh ukraine the situation with russia and
the other elements my foreign office
portfolio so you'll have to forgive me
i've not discussed that with him um
we've been discussing uh things like
iran ukraine all right
all right
well let me ask you uh uh maybe a
simpler more direct question about uh
if you like
his mind and the way it works which
frankly you will know better than
most
if he were to get
a fixed penalty notice and therefore by
implication in some way has broken the
law will he resign
i think what the prime minister and this
is reinforced by the uh the
conversations that i've had with him and
the announcements that he's made
publicly i think the prime minister is
focused on continuing with the work that
we've done beating yeah but yeah but he
would he would be pretty focused
he'd be pretty focused on the penalty
notice he gets will he resign if he gets
one
well i don't think uh i don't think what
the country needs at the moment is a
vacuum at the center of government when
we are dealing with our recovery from
covid the accumulation of russian troops
on the ukrainian border um making sure
that the uh the health service is able
to deal with the sad but unfortunately
unfortunate but but nevertheless uh um
obvious backlog that has been created by
kovic that's what the country needs
that's what um that's what i believe the
prime minister should uh should be doing
well i'm taking that as a no minister
thank james cleverley thank you very
much indeed
you're taking introverts exactly how you
should be taking it